mais derrière c'est une liste de gauche
qui est à la troisième place celle de
julien bayou pour europe ecologie les
verts est une question que tout le monde
se posait à l'issue du premier tour des
élections régionales la gauche va-t-elle
s'unir pour le second tour
eléonore sinoquet bonsoir bonsoir et
réaliste de la rédaction de tv 60,18
vous êtes avec nous pour répondre
justement à cette question alors union
ou pas pour la gauche pour le second
tour il y aura bien une union une liste
commune pour la gauche en ile de france
c'est julien bayou comme vous l'avait
dit et de liste europe écologie les
verts qui l'a annoncé sur twitter cet
après midi et qui la conduira cette
liste dimanche 27 juin prochain pour le
second tour des élections régionales
en effet à l'issue du premier tour de
ces élections y asseoir six listes
étaient qualifiés pour le second tour
il n'y en aura finalement que quatre
après avoir refusé de s'allier dès le
premier tour les trois listes de gauche
ont choisi de faire liste commune pour
tenter de renverser aussi bien la
présidente sortante
valérie pécresse divers droite qui
comptabilisait 35 96 % des voix mais
aussi pour éviter une percée du
rassemblement national avec jordan
bardella à sa tête en ile de france qui
se place en deuxième position avec 13
12% des voix alors dans le détail ces
trois listes dont celle de julien bayou
bayou pardon je vous en parlais à
l'instant il est tête de liste pour le
parti écologiste europe ecologie les
verts dont il est le secrétaire général
ce dimanche soir il a fait un bon score
avec 12 95% des voix le classant en
troisième position du scrutin
une véritable surprise cette troisième
position finalement il a réussi un vrai
tour de force pour s'imposer comme
première force politique de gauche est
déjà derrière soir on appelait au
rassemblement
du côté des écologistes lorsque la
gauche et l'écologie réunit est la
première force politique du pays
le temps est venu de se rassembler
j'appelle ce soir les listes de gauche
et de l'écologie à se retrouver et à
fusionner partout où elles le peuvent
quels sont les deux autres listes à
faire partie de cette alliance alors
d'abord la 2e minute grégory c'est celle
d'audrey pulvar ancien journaliste est
aujourd'hui adjoint mais à la maire ps
de paris anne hidalgo elle a obtenu avec
sa liste ile-de-france en commun 11 03 %
la classant en cinquième position du
scrutin
là encore dimanche soir après l'annoncé
des résultats audrey pulvar tout comme
julien bayou appelait au rassemblement
et à l'unité pour le résultat soit dans
une énorme le responsable
la liste île des comores se tait à leur
disposition dans le chemin de la rue
entre la gauche ou vers lui et lui
assurer au logis dernière et troisième
liste pour l'alliance celle de
clémentine autant estampillé france
insoumise et parti communiste français
sa liste pouvoir vivre en ile de france
est arrivé en sixième et dernière
position pour se maintenir au second
tour
pour clémentine autain une hier soir
c'était surtout l'abstention qui l'a
fait réagir que je crois que nous devons
avoir d'abord monté c'est que ce soir
pour le pays c'est un crash démocratique
après cette réaction clémentine autant a
aussi appelé tout comme ses deux
confrères de la gauche au rassemblement
pour sa tête de liste dans les yvelines
nelly duthu du parti communiste français
le rassemblement aurait dû être fait dès
le premier tour malgré les différences
dès le premier tour bon ça c'est pas
fait après ça a laissé les gens regarder
les programmes des uns et des autres
parce que sont faut pas se cacher sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes quand même
chacun a ses spécificités on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord sur un
programme deux régions qu'on peut le
défendre et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut se battre
arrivé le premier des trois listes de
gauche c'est donc tout naturellement que
julien bayou qu'on dira conduira cette
liste commune quoi qu'il en soit grégory
si l'on peut retenir une chose ou au
moins se poser une question pourquoi ne
pas s'être allié dès le premier tour et
surtout est ce que la gauche aurait pu
battre en s'alliant valérie pécresse
rien n'est moins sûr réponse dimanche
prochain le 27 juin pour le second tour
souvent tour des élections régionales
merci à l'honneur pour ce point complet